some good news for you for you for you
and for people who are coming here to
las vegas our resorts you know we've
long wanted international travelers to
come back well now the border with
canada and mexico is going to reopen in
just a few weeks covent travel limits
are being now lifted for those who have
received the covet 19 vaccine bianca
holman joining us now live in the
newsroom to explain bianca hey good
morning heather good morning john these
limits will be lifted for the first time
since march 2020 major news as more
people become vaccinated and travel
picks up for the past 19 months vehicle
rail and ferry travel between u.s canada
and mexico has been largely restricted
to essential travel only so unlike
flying for which you need proof of the
negative covid 19 tests to board an
international flight no testing will be
required by land or sea as long as you
meet the vaccination requirement
travelers can enter the u.s for
non-essential activities like visiting
family tourism and just seeing the
sights the department of homeland
security will exempt those who are fully
vaccinated against covet 19. now this is
these limits being lifted are just in
time for the holidays and this will all
start in early november bianca holman
live local now